i'm not clear what you mean by that
there's a memory of the of the state but
either way when you say that there's the
big bang and then there's an entropic
arrow
there's a huge mystery a mystery in
physics about the arrow of time like
what is time and why does it move
forward is it static like you mentioned
if we conceptualize the world in
classical non-constructivist mathematics
then there's no room for time
what is time in your model
it's time fundamental
um i think that if you uh want to have
an observer you need to have a system
that is multi-stable
and it
it's
moving between these states right it
needs to be able to be influenced by the
environment and as a result form some
kind of memory the memory means that
as a result of an observation at the
system-made environment it's changing
its internal state in a particular
deterministic way
and
the way that we
describe our universe we noticed that
we can
describe our universe in terms of states
of which some
explain this current state by being its
past
you could also say imagine you enumerate
all the possible universe states and
some of these states will look like they
contain the memory of past states
because they are can be the result of a
state transition where you are using a
permutation on previous bits basically
the laws of physics and you get to the
next state and as if you go backwards
you get a timeline
and all the possible timelines in the
space of uh the enumeration of universe
states these are all the possible
temporally extended universes from the
perspective of an observer
time is in some sense the
rate of change in the environment as
observed by the observer which means
it's relative to the rate of change in
the observer so from observer
perspective time is intrinsically
relativistic
from uh the perspective uh of outside of
the system which we cannot take
time would be state transition so there
is a way in which you would enumerate
the states by defining a function that
orders them
okay you just mentioned from the
perspective of of an observer outside
the system now in general relativity an
observer is what follows the time-like
curve okay so you're in the cone it
can't be spaced like can't be null now
if you ask what's what what the heck is
the experience of a photon we can't do
that because an observer is defined as
what's in the time-like cone the thing
is the photon is not multi-stable the
photo does not change state right that's
why the photon is not able to observe
the photon can be absorbed and
re-emitted with different properties but
by itself the photon doesn't change
and uh only a system that is able to
change state can observe and so uh
whenever you have a particle system like
you and me right a single one a single
one though what about a single particle
uh it depends what kind of particle but
uh
so in some sense you can describe every
uh particle system as some kind of a
compound particle
but it's basically depends on whether
you can uh change a property of of that
particle without that particle
uh changing its identity so to speak
right so as
as soon as this model of the particle
that no longer applies you
use a different description